as the foremost ufc specialist do you
want to talk about kane velasquez 100
greatest mma journalists of all time so
cain velasquez i don't know if you've
heard this story ryan
what is it do you know who cain
velasquez is i know he is okay so
basically he was a ufc
so basically what happened was uh he
found out that uh there was somebody
that was molesting his kid i think this
kid was four years old and it might have
happened
i saw bisping say this on rogue it might
have happened up to like a hundred times
whoa he found this out and that person
was i guess arrested and then let off
with like a slap on the wrist yeah so he
went and
shot at him and they ended up hitting
that person's stepfather
who might have been the reason why he
was molesting in the first place i don't
know their relationship but the
stepfather could have definitely diddled
in some [ __ ] molesting traits
molesting family it could be honestly
that's kind of how that should happen i
don't know if it happened from the
father or maybe the stepfather maybe not
at all but like i actually flipped the
tables i molest my dad that's a smart
genius so uh basically
so basically he went after him and
because he didn't get justice he went
after he's like i'm gonna take justice
into my own hands and shot at him ended
up shooting the stepfather not the
person but now everybody's out here like
yo i understand why you go crazy you let
the courts try to handle it they let off
the person that diddled your [ __ ] kid
you're just gonna let that happen yeah
there's no way and he's in front of a
school this [ __ ] might be at it
again
i gotta stop this guy he shot at him in
front of a school now that's my only
issue is don't shoot at him in front of
a school you're a ufc fighter just beat
the
[ __ ] out of him yeah because you don't
want a straight bullet to hit a kid i'm
the [ __ ] if it hits his step dad yeah he
just beat his ass to within an inch of
his life it's also way more
understandable even if the damage is
worse you know what i mean like if you
shoot a guy on a leg versus beat the
[ __ ] out of him like shooting him is
worse in the eye of like the society
beating the [ __ ] at him i'm like oh i
can forgive that even if that's a worse
punishment yeah it's just assault yeah
exactly it's like oh yeah you beat up a
guy even if his [ __ ] brain is ruined
forever versus getting shot in the leg
yeah there's never any like you shoot
someone and it's just assault beating
his ass it's attempted murder every
single time raise your shoulder yeah
yeah isn't it or no no so you can like
shoot someone in the leg and people are
like that's just assault i mean like if
you shoot in the air if you don't shoot
at the person if you're pointing the gun
out of person usually they go attempt at
murder right i don't know that's just
can he can he plead uh momentary
insanity
they gotta let him off for this right
can't you go listen uh the guy who
touched my [ __ ] four-year-old kid a
hundred times is in front of me not if
you guys look down and showed up
so much intent yeah
how long can you be momentarily insane
how long is the moment
yeah no i might be insane until the
guy's dead like that what happened
i thought it was a family member i
didn't know this was a kid if somebody
touches your kid i think the moment of
insanity is probably a year or two yeah
like it's probably a long ass moment how
long have you all been mad i was mad for
two hours this morning with the 62
degrees
i bought a gun for this miami place
recently
that's what i'm talking about okay
[ __ ] batman over here he's right
though you go if you're what's the point
of being a ufc fighter if you got to get
your gun involved and we would feel
physically like do you remember that
larry nassar moment where one of the
he's in on trial and one of the fathers
of the daughter charges at him yeah he's
like let me get [ __ ] fight with him
he charges at him and your heart breaks
for this guy because they stop him
before he could get his hands on larry
nassar because you want that you'll beat
his [ __ ] ass that's what you would
want for a ufc fighter to find this guy
and then just [ __ ] destroy his face
but what was the pedophile shooting at
him is less satisfying here's a question
though you go because if you're a ufc
fighter isn't it true that your hands
are registered weapons yeah so was he
not either way he's in the same
situation he registers the weapons yeah
you don't actually have to register i
think they're just it's automatically
registered
yeah what if you're trash what if you're
there's no [ __ ] permanent record
anywhere so that's a myth yes i think it
is i think it is a hundred percent oh
okay you can't beat me i think i think
boxing is there specifically apparently
bruce lee is the one that like
popularized that and it was kind of like
a marketing thing
it's like it has some truth in it
apparently
that like if you are like you know how
to fight and you attack someone like you
can be held at a higher penalty yeah
like soldiers higher penalty but not
like a firearm
i get my only issue is just beat the
[ __ ] out of him well maybe he didn't be
as he's like that guy could be strapped
too yeah and you don't know what weight
class the pedophile is but he didn't try
to kill him right he just shot in the
leg no he shot at him and missed and
then he hit the step down i think twice
which is fine my stepdad is gonna live
yeah killing him with fists is messier
that's for sure in front of a schoolyard
yeah i don't even know if you need to
kill him but just beating the [ __ ]
maybe he's trying to send another
message to all the other pedophiles
around the school yeah there's probably
other pedophiles watching into a van you
know he could have saved the kids
think about it there was a pedophile
about to molest a kid and then start
bucking off and he goes to heroes
[ __ ] was scouting he was hunting
no we're saying a different pedophile i
was like oh get that guy off there's
some girl meeting a 50 year old guy for
pizza that just got like a a message
being like you know what let's not meet
at that point
y'all
[Applause]
you